hey guys this is Vadim with max sec and
today we're gonna be playing some games
on both the iPhone 11 Pro Max and the
Galaxy Note 10.1 and some modern combat
5 because each of those games support
60fps on both of the phones the main
purpose of this video is to test the
gaming performance on each of these
phones and mainly the battery life so
we've set both phones to 100% battery
life we've turned off bluetooth we've
turned off all the background apps we
turn off high performance mode on the
note 10 plus and we've set the
brightness to the exact same level on
each phone by looking at the zebra
stripes on our camera and this is the
exact same test we ran on the iPhone 10s
max so after the test is done we're
gonna see the difference between the
battery life on the 10s max in the
iPhone 11 Pro Max and of course the note
10 plus so let's get right into the game
alright so here we are on the note 10
plus let's get into the settings right
here show you guys we're at high 100%
resolution 60 fps these are the settings
we'll be playing on the iPhone 11 Pro
Max and let's get into a game we are now
in game and definitely feel that 60 FPS
a little bit of dropped frames while
moving but still it's impressive finally
we get 60 FPS displays nice and bright
really colorful whoa
so far so smooth so I've noticed that
with 60 FPS the performance is pretty
good so far but there are some dropped
frames every now then you can kind of
see them not very much but just like
that you guys see that
whoa fortnight just crashed so we're
back in game and I think it's frozen I
mean it's stuck here there it goes whoa
it's kind of late
the heck it's like it keeps touching
this somehow it's like hitting this by
itself so far the gameplay looks pretty
smooth but it almost seems like the
display has dimmed a little bit since we
started so I'm definitely starting to
feel the back of the phone heat up a
little bit not as much as the iPhone
tennis max but now that the note 10 plus
is playing at 60fps it's definitely
getting more hot and I think the display
is getting dimmer so the really weird
thing on the note 10 plus is that you're
getting a lot more sound from this
speaker because it's definitely louder
than the earpiece speaker all right here
we are in fortnight on the iPhone 11 Pro
Max is heading to the settings
we're on high 60fps show fps is on just
like on the notes hand and let's get
into game alright so right away I can
tell that the display is smaller than on
the note 10 plus and of course you get
this notch right here that you don't get
on the notes you get that little cutout
on the note that definitely does not
look as bad as this and of course it
feels amazing super smooth 60fps oh wow
so basically before on the tennis max
there would be times like getting off
the bus that you might see a couple of
drop frames but to be honest right here
I did not see a single drop frame ever
since I got into this game oh I see you
guy let's chase him Hey
stop running oh friend oh come on man
man I've got to say the game place
perfect
I'm also absolutely loving the speakers
as well they get so loud and one thing
I'm noticing is that they're very
balanced between the top and bottom
speaker unlike the note where most of
the sound is coming from here the
earpiece speaker on the note is really
really weak oh no
come on man all right so I'm really
impressed by the 11pro max because at
this time on the tennis max the display
was dimming a lot so I'm really
impressed by the efficiency of the a13
chip Oh destroyed if you can't notice
the difference in performance it'll
definitely notice the difference in
display brightness because the elephant
Pro is so bright and it's not dimming
and I thought it was just a glitch on
the note 10 but I kept accidentally
going into build mode but I realized
that was actually the edge on the note
10 plus that was making me go into build
mode all the time you don't get that on
the iPhone all right so now we're
playing vainglory on the note 10 plus
and now we get 60fps on this game though
yo got him yeah Adam so 60 fps and
vainglory actually feels pretty nice
definitely better than before oh no whoa
got him okay I can't even touch me gotta
say this is too easy
oh it's coming yes got him this came is
a blast and man it feels perfectly
smooth on this phone no issues on the
note 10 + feels amazing only issue is
that you can easily block the speaker
notice that was easy look at that score
6 0 4 so far think Laura's been playing
perfectly on the note 10 + it's not
really getting hot or anything it's just
working very well at 60 frames per
second all right here we are in
vainglory on the iPhone 11 Pro Max and
let's test it out
so just like on the note 10 feels really
good whoa gotcha man this is kind of
easy feels really smooth just like on
the note 10 + no issues at all with that
60 FPS feels amazing on this game as
well no problem bro boom let's get this
dude
God don't eat me Oh easy all right
this was really fun that was easy look
at that 5-0 so basically I've noticed
that this phone can handle basically any
game you throw at it because the 812
bionic handled any game you could throw
at it so this is even better with even
more graphics performance in the note 10
plus of course is similar to the tennis
max from last year with the 812 Bionic
ship and here we are in modern combat 5
on the note 10 plus let's see how it
plays
don't kill me bro with that watch me
nade this do - ah man be honest this
isn't the most graphically demanding
game but it's definitely pretty fun
feels really smooth so far that's okay
so that's how I aim how do I reload this
game is definitely fun but you got to
get competitive players to play against
because this is kind of easy
let's go man look how easy this is man
this is nothing these are like all BOTS
man they suck so far this game is
obviously playing really good as well
feels really smooth no issues at all
there you go guys it's been an hour
playing on the galaxy note end we're at
80% battery life Wow 80 percent battery
life that's actually really good
alright guys here we are in the iPhone
11 pro max playing modern combat 5 let's
do this alright Tommy
Oh silver League
alright so these guys are definitely not
BOTS these guys know what they're doing
yeah Adam and just like on the note 10
Plus this phone feels amazing on this
game 60fps feels awesome woah man that
guy's good ok I'll get him I'll get him
got him
yo stop running man that keeps running
got him yep got him
Oh John are you kidding man all right
I'll get him one of these days man so
feels great on the iPhone it's not hot
at all the bat feels really cool in this
game
definitely an easier game all right guys
it's been an hour on the iPhone 11 Pro
Macs and let's check the battery life we
are at 83% 83% on the iPhone 11 pro max
that is really impressive all right guys
so we just finished playing one hour on
each phone and to my surprise the iPhone
11 pro max was at 83 percent battery
life while the note 10 plus was only at
80% it's very close what I was actually
expecting it to go the other way around
because the note 10 plus has a 4,300
milliamp hour battery compared to 39 69
on the iPhone 11 pro max so this has a
larger battery and we played for an hour
on both phone equal brightness Bluetooth
off everything the same that is really
really shocking and this improvement is
awesome because we did the same test on
the iPhone tennis max and we were only
able to get 69% battery life after an
hour instead of 83 on the iPhone 11 Pro
Max and another improvement on the
iPhone 11 pro max is that it didn't get
as hot as the tennis max from last year
while playing fortnight at 60fps which
seems to be probably the most demanding
game that I can currently find on the
App Store so I'm really really impressed
by the 11pro max now between these two
phones they both did an excellent job
playing at 60 fps and vainglory in
modern combat 5 no real gameplay
differences there now in fortnight we
did notice more drop frames on the note
10 plus I'm not sure if that's just the
Android software side of it or it's the
difference in power between these two
but the iPhone 11 pro max was able to
play each game flawlessly no issues at
all so let's answer the original
question which phone is better for
gaming
this time I honestly think it is now the
iPhone 11 Pro max just because of that
awesome battery life and excellent
performance through any game we tried in
that we're not getting dimming like we
did on the tennis max Xtreme dimming
that we used to get from overheating we
don't see that anymore so it seems like
this is the best package overall the
best smartphone for gaming in 2019 and
going into 2020 thanks for watching guys
I hope you enjoyed that video if you're
not already subscribed click that circle
above and check out some of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]